qu'est ce qui s'est passé quand je suis
allé au vietnam
tu es revenu très bien mais quand je
suis allé en mission au darfour
tu es revenu du parent j'ai détesté ça
mais je suis toujours
une douzaine de terroristes préparent
une sacrée fiesta
on ne sait pas exactement où et quand
ils achètent mais ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'il ya une information quelque part
celui que j'ai choisi ces vous bien
monsieur visite perdre et nafie
j'ai obéi aux ordres peeters il s'agit
d'une mission suicide
quel est tombé dans le coma
est ce que la formation est récupérable
c'est un processus qui détruirait notre
a chargé le risque qui n'était pas
l'assumer
en acceptant cette mission pour le tuer
il faudra me passer sur le corps
c'est quoi ces missions
deiss le deuil sa femme essaye de
récupérer la formation
je te prétends rien dit
ne vous mêlez pas de plaque les
informations que vous détenez pas sauver
des millions de vie n'est qu'une seule
fille qui m'apporte
vous devez accepter la réalité de la
situation
bienvenue dans le monde du nano terreur